- All right, so Demi,
you've been very vocal
which I appreciate because
we have gigantic platforms
that I think we should use.
But you've been pretty vocal
about Black Lives Matter,
so what do you think, personally,
that we can all do differently?
- I think the first step
is educating ourselves.
We have a lot of time
on our hands right now.
There's no reason why
we shouldn't be watching
these movies, watching and absorbing
all information that we possibly can
about what's going on in the world.
And then from there, we've seen it
all over the media that being silent
and being not-racist
is not enough anymore.
And that's kind of something
that I posted about.
Like a month ago when the
Ahmaud Arbery stuff happened,
I was like, I felt, I saw online
what had happened and I
felt this overwhelming sense
of frustration, anger, I was like crying
and I started writing in my phone.
I just got all my
emotions and I felt guilty
that I hadn't been doing
more and saying more
as an ally but I was also afraid
that people were going to come at me.
- Because they will.
- Yeah, so because
everybody's angry right now
and I just didn't want anyone to think
that I had the wrong intentions.
Or that I was uneducated, you know?
Like, speaking about something
that I didn't know about,
that was a fear of mine.
And so I kind of, when that happened,
and even before I found
out about George Floyd.
I was like, "No, I need to do more.
"I need to be an ally.
"I have not been an ally."
I have, like Aretha
Franklin, Billie Holiday,
Whitney Houston, these women of color
have shaped my musical journey
and how am I supposed to appreciate
what they've given me and not stand up
for their community?
And so I just, I switched my thinking
and then all of this happened.
And you know, I wish I had kinda come
to that realization sooner but I think
everything happens in it's own timing
and I've gotten to a place where like,
because I'm able to
deal with my own demons
and my own things, I can now kind of help
advocate for other people.
And I think maybe that's a reason
why some people aren't
speaking out and doing things,
is they're afraid but they're also
not ready to help other people.
I don't know, I just wanted to be
the ally that I know I can be
and I want to be able
to share the thinking
as much as possible because the legacy
that I will leave as a person
will last so much longer than the music
that we leave behind.
- Yeah, totally, your
character means everything.
I agree.